oh I reach for
you this is taking me back
[Music]
manall he says explicitly Heaven Gates
won't up open up for me so he's alluding
he's referring directly to religion
saying prison Gates won't open up for me
I'm on these hands and knes I'm crawling
the prison of this Mortal life this
terrestrial World which is fallen and
broken and involves each of us
committing sins and incurring debts that
we can't pay I'm reaching for you with
while while I'm terrified of these four
walls the these iron bars can't hold my
soul in so he's saying right I I might
be constrained to death and Brokenness
because of because we're in a fallen
world but my soul yearns for something
else and will not be constrained by the
Brokenness of this world all I need is
you come please I'm calling I I actually
think this is a religious song